je suis évidemment heureux d'être de
nouveau devant vous je vais revenir
d'emblée sur deux points que vous avez
abordé pour alors aller ensuite vers mon
propos de présentation de ce budget 2022
d'abord en vous remerciant de ce que
vous avez dit en commençant sur le fait
que
j'avais pu battre un record de longévité
[Musique]
ça n'a pas d'importance de personnel
mais servent d'importants sion soit sur
le fait que nous avons besoin de sion
long dans le système éducatif et si j'ai
dit dès 2017 que c'était mon souhait
d'arriver à rester cinq ans dans cette
fonction c'était précisément pour bien
indiquer que nous avons besoin de cela
une bonne partie des choses dont je vous
parlais sont des graines que nous avons
sommet dont parfois il ya les premiers
bourgeons mais qui sont qui nécessite
forcément le temps long même si nous
sommes tous impatients pour de voir
certains résultats je l'évoquerai tout à
l'heure parce que des résultats il y en
a mais il ya aussi des choses qui sont
en train de se balancer donc merci pour
ce que vous avez dit là j'en profite
pour dire ce message là qui est que quoi
qu'il arrive dans les années décennies à
venir pour notre pays on peut souhaiter
que ce que le ministère d'éducation
nationale sur un sujet à la fois de
stabilité et aussi je dirais de débat
fait de la passion qui exige l'éducation
mais aussi d'une forme de
d'abstraction des querelles politiques
trop forte qui ne font pas du mien
écoles on a besoin d'eux
d'avoir le sens de l'intérêt général
partagez ce qui n'exclut pas le débat
mais doit permettre toujours de
rechercher l'intérêt des élèves et puis
deuxième remarque puisque juste titre
vous avez dit que sara lee s'était
prononcé très clairement ce matin nous
en parlions encore à l'instant je veux
puisque j'ai pas eu l'occasion de le
faire publiquement dire à mon tour
exactement ce qu'elle a pu dire que nous
disons ensemble c'est à dire que bien
sûr nous considérons comme inacceptable
cette campagne du conseil de l'europe
je considère ça comme très grave
je considère d'ailleurs que l'incident
n'est pas clos parce que ça révèle
quelque chose qu'une chose que j'ai déjà
dénoncé dans le passé c'est à dire de
fait que des associations des structures
qui ne vont pas dans le sens des valeurs
de la république régis à s'insinuer dans
des institutions
même les parmi les plus importantes
comme le conseil de l'europe et ce qui
s'est passé là n'est pas acceptable et
d'ailleurs n'est pas acceptée
s'agissant donc de la présentation du
budget pour la cinquième année donc je
vous présente le budget de
l'enseignement scolaire c'est donc
naturel comme vous l'avez dit que ce
soit l'heure des premiers bilans
et leur notamment de d'indiquer à quel
point cela a été une priorité de ce
quintette quinquennat puisque c'était un
budget d'investissement dans l'école la
nation soudanais moyen de faire de
l'école un levier de réussite pour tous
les élèves en agissant dès le plus jeune
âge en offrant à chacun d'entre eux la
possibilité progressive de personnaliser
son orientation pour réussir pleinement
son intégration dans la vie
professionnelle
le fait qu'il la création d'un
secrétariat d'état en charge de
l'éducation prioritaire
l'année dernière il ya maintenant un an
et demi est très significatif avec
madame et limaces en charge de cela de
notre de notre priorité sociale dans ce
budget de l'éducation et puis avec sarah
et la grille à mes côtés la question de
la jeunesse évidemment renforcée et avec
l'arrivée du ministère des sports avec
ma avec madame roxana maracineanu que
vous avez auditionné le 26 octobre nous
avons désormais un grand ministère et là
aussi puisqu'on parlait de pérennité je
voudrais dire à quel point il me semble
souhaitable que l'éducation nationale
jeunesse et sport soit avoir longtemps
réuni que ça ne dépendent pas des
quinquennats successifs mais que ce soit
de choses de structurellement inscrits
puisque vous le savez il s'agit d'avoir
une vision complète du temps de l'enfant
dans de la grande ligne de ce que
certains de mes prédécesseurs comme jean
zay avait pu inscrire dans le marbre
c'est à dire une vision de l'éducation
dans le temps scolaire mais de
l'éducation au delà du temps scolaire et
donc c'est
important de dieu je suis heureux de
voir avec cette équipe nous sommes
quatre de faire une grande équipe de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports pour entrer directement dans
les chiffres le budget de la mission
enseignement scolaire qui vous est
proposé pour 2022 s'établit à 55 2
milliards d'euros donc hors cotisations
de l'état c'est ce qui explique la
différence avec le chiffre que vous avez
donnée qui est inclue les pensions de
l'état cela représente par rapport à
l'année dernière une augmentation de 3 %
1 6 milliard d'euros supplémentaire
c'est évidemment considérable c'est une
des plus grande augmentation en
pourcentage depuis longtemps avec cette
nouvelle très nette augmentation
nous poursuivons la transformation du
système et des éducatifs l'école à trois
ans la priorité à l'école primaire j'y
reviendrai évidemment le dédoublement en
éducation prioritaire le les devoirs
faits au collège la réforme du lycée
général et technologique et du lycée
professionnel l'école inclusive les
sites et éducative les internats
d'excellence autant d'éléments qui sont
visés par ce budget parce qu'évidemment
l'augmentation du budget n'est pas une
fin en soi mais ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir des priorités et je le dis
très clairement depuis 2010 est la
priorité des priorités c'est l'école
primaire et cela se voit dans ce budget
alors le premier point que je voudrais
souligné c'est le fait que le budget de
l'éducation nationale a augmenté de 13 %
en cinq ans c'est un record là aussi
c'est la première fois qu'il ya une
telle augmentation sur cinq années en
2017 il était de 48 8 milliards d'euros
en 2022 il sera de 55,2 milliards
d'euros c'est donc une hausse de 13%
comme j'ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
que je viens de dire c'est pas de la
littérature c'est des mathématiques on
sait autrement dit c'est totalement
irréfutables
et je le dis par rapport à des discours
qu'on peut entendre parfois sur le fait
que l'éducation seraient négligés ou ou
qu'on ne ferait pas attention au service
public de l'éducation dont il n'y a
jamais eu une telle augmentation après
mais toujours y avoir un débat sur la
manière dont nous affectons l'argent
mais c'était que healy a
incontestablement une augmentation
inédite du budget de l'éducation
nationale mais et c'est ainsi si je
compare avec les précédents en
quinquennat de 2000 j'avais déjà fait
cette comparaison pour de 2012 à 2016 on
m'avait éventuellement contester cette
cette coupure du temps donc même si on
le fait de 2013 à 2017 et comparé à 2018
2022 vient de 2013 à 2017 c'est 4,5
milliards d'augmentation de 2018 à 2020
de ses 6 6 4 donc c'est clairement
davantage et ça je pense que voilà
personne ne peut dire le contraire c'est
encore une fois il suffit de vérifier
dans les documents budgétaires
donc si on considère la seule masse
salariale on a augmenté de 5,4 milliards
d'euros c'était 3 7 milliards d'euros
dans le quinquennat précédent qu'en plus
nous avons stabilisé les emplois ce qui
fait qu'en terme de pouvoir d'achat la
manière dont tout ceci s'est diffusé
dans
le dans les salaires et les
rémunérations des professeurs et des
personnels c'est davantage que dans tous
les mandats précédents
donc ça c'est la donne et je dirais
quantitative en valeur absolue
maintenant il ya une deuxième point sur
lequel je voulais insister c'est que
nous voulons évidemment que ceux ci
soient au service de la revalorisation
financière du métier d'enseignant et
donc de son attractivité conformément à
la question que vous posiez tout à
l'heure dans le dans le prolongement du
grenelle de l'éducation
le il s'agit donc d'avoir un véritable
lien concret pour les professeurs et
d'enclencher un mouvement qui a vocation
je l'espère à aller au delà de 2022 vous
le savez il y avait trois axes retenus
dans le grenelle de l'éducation qui
m'ont amené à 12 engagements c'était
d'abord la meilleure reconnaissance pour
attirer diversifiée et conserver les
talents
c'était l'esprit d'équipé donc un esprit
de coopération dans l'ensemble du
système scolaire et en troisième lieu
l'ouverture du champ des possibles
autrement dit permettent les mobilités
professionnelles
en plus de la reconnaissance
professionnelle
s'agissant du premier point c'est à dire
de la reconnaissance la revalorisation
attendue est au rendez vous en 2021 vous
le savez ces 400 millions d'euros qui
étaient venus abonder le budget pour
revaloriser les personnels cette année
ses 700 millions d'euros qui viennent
s'y ajouter
et tout ceci s'est fait en même temps
que l'agenda social qui a permis de
dégager des lignes force
d'abord on nous avons cherché à
toucher toutes les catégories de
personnel et puis nous avons porté une
attention particulière à tous les débuts
de carrière parce que lorsqu'on se
compare aux autres pays de l' ocde en
particulier c'est là que la différence
est la plus forte donc une prime
d'attractivité a été créée et sera versé
en août a été versé en mai 2021 pour la
première fois elle est valorisée
revaloriser étendu pour février 2022
l'exemple marco on sait que randy moi
donc de mai 2021 février 2022 les néo
titulaires auront vu leur rémunération
progresser de 157 euros nets mensuels
ceci s'ajoute à d'autres
d'autres éléments de revalorisation je
pense à la prime d'équipements
informatiques qui renouvelait les 250
euros nets annuels elle a été créée
aussi en 2021 en 2022 il y aura 200
millions d'euros consacrés à la
protection sociale complémentaire ça
signifie 15 euros par mois pour tous les
agents du ministère de l'éducation
nationale
dans le but de les aider dans le fait
d'avoir une protection sociale
complémentaire de façon globale les
crédits de masse salariale font l'objet
d'une augmentation nette de près de 1
milliard 200 millions d'euros qui
bénéficie donc à l'ensemble des
personnels pour la revalorisation de
leur carrière c'est évidemment un point
majeur
troisième point que je voudrais
souligner c'est la priorité pour l'école
primaire c'est l'effort donc fait en
faveur du premier degré qui se voit
budget après budget et donc nous
approfondissons le sillon
comme vous savez il ya une baisse
démographique qui se poursuit il faut
d'ailleurs le déplorer
quatre-vingt mille élèves en moins à la
rentrée 2022 mais nous maintenons les
emplois à l'école primaire
et donc depuis 2010 est nous aurons créé
près de 9000 postes dans le premier
degré alors qu'il y à 285 mille élèves
en moins
c'est totalement assumée comme politique
pour avoir un meilleur taux
d'encadrement rentrée après rentrer dans
chaque département de france et puis
pour prendre des mesures spécifiques des
mesures ciblées bien sûr
certaines sont déjà réalisés d'autres
sont en cours de réalisation ce qui est
réalisé c'est l'accueil d'élèves
supplémentaires à l'école maternelle
c'est les conséquences de l'abaissement
de la scolarité à trois ans je voudrais
souligner l'importance de cette mesure
qui n'est pas que symbolique aujourd'hui
et faire à fortiori en contexte
épidémique elle insiste sur l'importance
de l'école maternelle
et à quel point l'école maternelle
détermine beaucoup de choses pour la
réussite des élèves ensuite à l'école
élémentaire et dans la suite de leur
parcours scolaire notamment si l'on veut
compenser les inégalités que ce soit sur
les sujets de maîtrise du français du
vocabulaire par exemple où les sujets de
maîtrise des mathématiques en deuxième
lieu
là aussi un objectif réaliser c'est le
dédoublement des classes de cp et de ce1
en référé plus vous le savez on
construit un que cette mesure-là
concerne trois cent mille élèves parents
et elle est
évidemment de la plus haute importance
est là c'est elle qui nous permet de
réduire l'écart en ce moment même entre
les élèves qui sont en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire et le reste du
pays ce qu'on a pu après un graal
éducatif un tous les pays cherchent ça
c'est à dire à ce que les territoires
les plus défavorisés rejoignent les
autres territoires dans leurs
performances scolaires et bien sûr graal
nous l'avons atteindre dans certains
endroits nous n'avons pas atteint
uniformément mais nous avons déjà des
classes de réseau d'éducation
prioritaire qui ont des taux de réussite
comparables à des territoires
favoriser l'exemple que j'ai donné à
plusieurs reprises c'est par exemple les
18e et 19e arrondissement de paris où
certaines écoles ont des résultats
comparables au 7ème arrondissement de
paris c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
inédit et qui montre la voie s'ils l'ont
fait c'est que tout le monde peut le
faire et cela montre bien que le
dédoublement des classes s'accompagne
aussi d'évolution pédagogique importante
je n'ai pas toutes les énumérer ne sont
pas forcément de nature budgétaire et je
plonge je pense en particulier à ce que
nous avons appelé le plan français et le
plan mathématique qui sont des plans de
formation continue des professeurs du
premier degré et qui permettent bien de
donner à nos professeurs tous les outils
pédagogiques à la lumière de ce que la
recherche en éducation permet de savoir
sur plan national et sur le plan
international
et c'est ainsi que se relèvent nos
compétences en lecture et nos
compétences en mathématiques
ce que j'affirmais que ce budget traduit
c'est que nous sommes au début d'une
remontée de pente alors que nous
déplorons depuis des décennies la baisse
du niveau en cp à l'école primaire en
particulier
la remontée du niveau est en train de se
réaliser forcément c'est un début mais
je voudrais le dire par rapport à des
débats que je vois là aussi
on ne peut pas parler de pisa 2018 pour
illustrer quoi que ce soit du bilan de
ce quinquennat je vois parfois des
articles ou des débats on dit la france
en déclin permanent mais pisa 2018 c'est
la photographie d'élèves de 15 ans à
l'année 2018 ça ne dit rien de ce qui a
été entrepris pour remonter le niveau à
partir de l'école primaire depuis 2017
et nous aurons dans une semaine les
résultats des évaluations de cp et de
ce1 et de 6e j'espère bien qu'elles
confirmeront sa tendance qu'on a
enregistré en février dernier dans les
évaluations de mi-parcours de cp c'est à
dire une capacité à rebondir
malgré la malgré la crise sanitaire et
alors même que nous savons donc que de
nom de nombreux pays le niveau est
malheureusement
va baisser du fait de que les écoles
n'ont pas été ouvertes donc le
dédoublement des classes et la pointe
avancée d'une politique plus générale
pédagogique de l'école primaire et puis
il y à d'autres mesures qui sont en voie
d'achèvement je pense est qu'ils sont
très concernés par ce budget puisque la
rentrée 2022 c'est le plafonnement à 24
élèves par classe pour toute la france
tous territoires confondus en grande
section cp français
qui sera qui a été encore engagée à la
rentrée 2020 poursuivi en 2021 au moment
où je vous parle ça concerne déjà 86%
des classes et ce sera 100 % à la
rentrée 2022 et puis là aussi dans les
choses en voie d'achèvement le
dédoublement des classes de grande
section
de maternelle en éducation prioritaire
à terme nous visons au cent cinquante
mille élèves parents et là aussi c'est
en voie d'achèvement
donc nous avons
là encore une politique de l'école
primaire qui se traduit dans ce budget
la maîtrise des savoirs fondamentaux dès
le plus jeune âge est une garantie
essentielle
pour l'avenir de notre pays pour les
deux objectifs que je me suis fixé
depuis le départ c'est à dire à
améliorer le niveau général et réduire
les inégalités sociales
le quatrième point que je voudrais
souligner illustré par ce budget c'est
le fait de parachever le grand service
public de l'école inclusive vous le
savez le président république avait fixé
comme priorité la scolarisation des
élèves en situation de handicap tout au
long du cours du quinquennat
et nous avons traduit cela par cette
notion de service public de l'école
inclusive
c'est un sujet difficile c'est un sujet
qui méritait des avancées quantitative
et qualitative
désormais toutes les directions
départementales de l'éducation nationale
ont un service école inclusive qui est
un service unique clairement
identifiable par les familles et les
professionnels et qui est un
interlocuteur pour les familles nous
avons généralisé l'épaule inclusif
d'accompagnement localiser les piannencs
depuis cette rentrée scolaire
le nombre d'élèves en situation de
handicap scolarisés est en constante
augmentation avec plus de 400 mille
élèves scolarisés à la rentrée 2021
ça fait cent mille de plus depuis le
début du quinquennat et donc ça signifie
qu'en 2022
c'est 3,5 milliards d'euros par an que
nous consacrons à l'école inclusive cela
représente 210 millions d'euros de plus
que l'année dernière ça signifie qu'on à
65 % d'augmentation depuis le début du
quinquennat de ce budget c'est
évidemment de très loin le budget qui
augmente le plus je pense que tailleur
donc secteurs de l'état confondues
avec
cette augmentation des deux tiers du
budget de l'école inclusive depuis
depuis 2010 est concrètement en 2022 ça
veut dire 4000 à eux est sage de plus
et donc c'est évidemment important il ya
désormais 120 milles 125000 adressage
dans le système scolaire français
et cela doit nous amener aussi à des
évolutions qualitatives en plus d
évolution quantitative je pense en
particulier à tout ce que nous faisons
en matière de formation 60 heures par an
organisation donc au travers des piats
qui est fait pour être au plus près des
besoins des élèves et des familles bien
sûr tout n'est pas parfait sur le
terrain j'en ai conscience
mais ce que j'affirme c'est que en cinq
ans on est passé d'un système où il y
avait soixante dix mille personnes en
contrat aidé à un système où il ya 125
mille personnes en cdd ou voir en cdi
que ce système sa compagne une
reconnaissance de cette fonction d'un
message d'une véritable carrière avec
désormais une grille indiciaire et ne
reconnaissance au sein du système
éducation nationale et c'est ce que j'ai
demandé à tous les recteurs cette
revalorisation
signifie dans ce budget 56 millions
d'euros consacrés aux avs h avec une
grille indiciaire et un avancement
automatique en fonction de l'ancienneté
il ya donc un véritable nouveau statut
des avs âge
et tout ceci se passe dans le cadre d'un
cadre de gestion que nous avons définies
en 2019 et va permettre de nouveaux
progrès notamment plus de plein temps
pour les avs h en 2022 et et une vision
au plus près des besoins de l'élève le
cinquième point que je voudrais
souligner c'est la dimension sociale des
mesures prises dans le cadre de ce
budget je ne pourrais pas être exhaustif
sur l'ensemble des mesures sociales mais
je voudrais ont donné trois reprises en
plein portant la hausse des bourses et
des fonds sociaux avec une enveloppe de
895 millions d'euros qui est en hausse
de 35 millions d'euros pour accompagner
les familles les plus défavorisées
7 ça inclut la revalorisation de la
prime d'internât
une revalorisation de 69 euros
l'extension de la bourse au mérite aux
élèves boursiers qui s'engagent à
l'issue de la troisième dans une
formation conduisant au ca p
l'ouverture du pass culture qui sera une
des petites révolutions de cette année
puisque le pass culture signifie que à
partir du mois de janvier nous
consacrons 25 euros par élève et par an
à partir de la classe de 4e aux sorties
collectives enfin vos dépenses collectif
culturel donc ça s'ajoute aux dépenses
individuelles
concrètement cela signifie qu dans une
classe de trente deux élèves ces 800
euros pour des sorties scolaires on
pensait que beaucoup de sorties
scolaires ne se font pas faute de
parfois quelques dizaines ou quelques
centaines d'euros
là on a évidemment un outil à la
disposition des professeurs pour arriver
à cet objectif de ce que nous avons
appelé 100% d'éducation artistique et
culturelle autrement dit que tous les
élèves de france soient concernés chaque
année par des par l'éducation artistique
et culturelle
nous avons inscrit 47 millions d euros
dans ce plfr pour cette première année
un deuxième exemple c'est la relance de
la politique des internats d'excellence
c'est vous le savez un outil auquel je
crois beaucoup parce que c'est la
meilleure manière de s'attaquer aux
facteurs extra scolaires de la réussite
scolaire en permettant à des élèves
d'origine modeste
souvent issus soit de milieux ruraux
soit dans deux quartiers de la politique
de la ville et bien d'avoir des
conditions de travail positive et des
ouvertures de vie sur le plan culturel
sur le plan sportif
à titre d'exemple avec le plan de
relance c'est 54 internationales ont été
sélectionnés et labellisé en 2021 et les
conventions seront toutes engagées avant
la fin de cette année et avec des
décaissements prévues tout au long de
l'année 2022 pour permettre l'ouverture
de 1500 places d'ici à la rentrée
scolaire 2022 tout ceci évidemment en
partenariat avec les collectivités
locales
et c'est souvent pour les collectivités
locales aussi une occasion de
revaloriser certains territoires
donc pour conclure et comme vous pouvez
le constater c'est un budget qui est à
la hauteur de nos objectifs il engage
une dynamique et des perspectives pour
notre jeunesse dans un instant vous
allez entendre sa raillerie qui de
manière très complémentaire va être
peuvent a montré pourquoi c'est aussi un
budget
qui valorise la jeunesse et le temps
extrascolaire de la jeunesse aussi
c'est un budget qui témoigne une
reconnaissance de la nation pour ses
professeurs et pour les profs personnels
de l'éducation nationale et c'est un
budget qui investit dans l'éducation de
nos enfants
et donc qui prépare la société de demain
donc je vous remercie et je laisse la
parole à madame sarah elle a écrit
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
messieurs le rapporteur madame la
rapporteure mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs effectivement le programme
jeunesse et vie associative que je porte
en réalité n'est que l'illustration
partielle des politiques publiques en
faveur de la jeunesse tellement ses
transversales mais également le soutien
à la vie associative la jeunesse
évidemment demeure je crois la priorité
de tous et c'est une évidence parce que
c'est notre avenir et parce qu'on a tous
envie qu'elle réussisse qu'elle
réussisse quel que soit bien ça dit sa
diversité sa ces bouts de vie ces
moments là jeunesse et une partie de
l'enfance une partie de l'adolescence
mais également un moment où on rentre
dans la vie dans la vie active
la particularité de ce budget c'est que
il est évidemment construit de manière
extrêmement partenariale avec les
services déconcentrés avec l'ensemble
des collectivités territoriales mais
aussi avec les acteurs du monde
associatif et l'éducation populaire en
particulier agir pour la jeunesse c'est
d'abord je crois je le disais au tout
début prendre en considération son
extrême diversité la jeunesse rurale
n'est pas la jeunesse urbaine n'est pas
cette jeunesse périurbaines et il faut
regarder chacune d'entre elles parce que
chacune d'entre elles a des talents à
des besoins mais aussi à des
opportunités à développer et donc c'est
le point sur lequel avec jean michel
blanc car avec le mythe de l'éducation
nationale on a souhaité et on souhaite
apporter des réponses extrêmement
multiples pour que chacune d'entre elles
savoir son propre car son propre
parcours c'est lui qui lui permettra
effectivement est bien de se construire
et d'être suffisamment forte pour l'âge
adulte ces crédits sont en augmentation
puisque il s'élève à 772 millions
d'euros pour 2022 et c'est une
progression de plus de 11% par rapport à
l'année dernière alors je pourrais en
parler pendant des heures mais le
président m'en voudrais donc je vais
accentuée en tout cas essayer d'apporter
les réponses aux questions préliminaires
qui ont été posées par le par le
président en particulier et donc appuyé
d'abord la forte mobilisation pour la
jeunesse notamment l'accompagnement vers
l'autonomie et ensuite évidemment la
lutte contre le non recours aux droits
sociaux accompagner la reprise c'est
aussi accompagner la reprise il soutien
au monde associatif qui a été ébranlée
par cette crise sanitaire de manière
financière et de manière humaine parce
qu'aujourd'hui se poser la mobilité la
question de la mobilisation des
bénévoles le retour des bénévoles dans
les associations
et ça je crois ça touche des
associations de toutes tailles de haies
de tout territoire
donc le programme jeunesse et vie
associative je disais une autre à ce
qu'une fraction de l'effort de la nation
dans ce domaine parce qu'il donne
l'impulsion il permet certes de
l'innovation mais surtout de la
coordination interministérielle est
évidemment de l'accompagnement humain je
développerai les aspects relatifs à la
jeunesse en m'appuyant sur peut-être de
trois mesures emblématiques est qui et
qui me tiennent particulièrement à coeur
le service national universel le
développement du service civique et le
soutien au mentorat et pour commencer en
m'appuyant sur les propos du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et les vôtre
monsieur le président le service
national universel aujourd'hui il a
vocation à apporter cette unité cette
transmission de valeurs cette
transmission aussi finalement de ce qui
fait de ce qui fait commun dans notre
pays ça rejoint et a réuni des jeunes de
15 à 17 ans ça vise à faire vivre un
temps de mixité sociale un moment
d'unité nationale nécessaire pour créer
ce good l' engagement et l'accompagner
il est composé évidemment de la phase du
séjour de cohésion qui est le plus connu
et je veux dire le plus visible mais il
est surtout également composé d'une
mission d'intérêt général et enfin d'un
engagement longue et la fameuse phase
iii alors il poursuivra son
développement en vue de sa
généralisation cette année c'est au
moins cinquante mille jeunes volontaires
qui seront accueillis pour un budget
proposé à 110 millions d'euros alors
même et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président que l'année dernière eh bien
nous avons du contenu des protocoles
sanitaires et dur le nombre de jeunes
accueillis alors même que les jeunes
étaient au rendez vous puisque plus de
30 mille inscrits était et est sûre
avait rejoint la plate forme et cette
action de volontariat pour accompagner
cette jeunesse est ce cette répétition
générale 6,6 peut l'exprimer comme ça et
bien 80 emplois de chef de projet senior
ont été créés et accompagneront cette
montée en charge au niveau des services
déconcentrés et au plus proche des
territoires pour que ce soit la maille
départementale qui soit la plus
renforcée puisque c'est celle qui
reconnaît là la spécificité de chaque
territoire continue évidemment le
renforcement du service civique qui est
qui peut être renforcée également parce
que c'est la phase iii du et c'est nul
c'est une des phases iii que ce soit
évidemment une mission de service
civique un corps vos de volontariat
européen ou encore rejoindre une réserve
de la gendarmerie ce qui me permet
également de saluer la mobilisation
particulièrement forte des cadets de la
gendarmerie sur l'ensemble des
territoires et je sais qu'un certain
nombre de sénateurs ils ont accompagné
ce développement depuis sa création le
service civique c'est ce projet majeur
de citoyenneté qui offrent finalement à
plus de 530 mille jeunes depuis le début
de sa création un moment je crois
d'intérêt général d'engagement
d'engagement très divers développement
de compétences et cette année c'est plus
de deux cent mille jeunes qui ont
vocation à s'engager en tout cas en dans
une mission de service civique des
thèmes prioritaires ont été développés
parce que c'est leur aspiration et parce
que les jeunes ont été au rendez vous
pendant cette crise la transition
environnementale la solidarité
intergénérationnelle qui est absolument
nécessaire je crois à la cohésion de
notre de notre pays mais aussi la
réussite sur tous les territoires parce
que c'est ce lien intergénérationnel
évidemment entre nos aînés et les plus
jeunes mais également entre les jeunes
eux mêmes et je crois que c'est la
beauté de de la préoccupation de l'autre
que le service civique permet son budget
consacré est stabilisé et on l'a budgété
à plus de 498 millions d'euros identique
à la halle à elle fit est là les filles
2021 un autre un autre pan ké absolument
qu'on se plaint qui construit et qui est
l'accompagnement et finalement de ce
temps à extra scolaires et périscolaires
également c'est évidemment le plan
mentorat dans un jeune une solution il
ya un dispositif spécifique qui a
vocation à accompagner les associations
qui développe le mentorat sur nos
territoires qu'ils soient pour les
étudiants pour les professionnels ou en
réalité par la mobilisation et bien
d'une partie des retraités qui ont
énormément de choses à transmettre
transmettre le goût de l'engagement
transmettent le des parcours de vie mais
aussi des formes d'engagement très
divers 27 millions d'euros qui sont
consacrés au soutien aux associations
pour accompagner d'ici la fin de cette
année cent mille jeunes et d'ici la fin
de l'année prochaine deux cent mille
jeunes c'est une ambition
importante puisque nous sommes partis de
plus de 20 mille jeunes environ dans
notre pays qui était tutoré sommes
entourés d'autres sections sont
évidemment porté au programme pour
soutenir les loisirs éducatifs l'accès à
la jeunesse à l'information parce que
c'est la première des inégalités quand
on ne sait pas que ça existait difficile
de s'en saisir et ses inégalités on n'a
pas vocation à les laisser et bien
s'enraciner
le soutien aussi aux accueils collectifs
de mineurs avec hébergement au centre de
vacances aux collines vacances mais
également aux accueils de scoutisme qui
transmettent le goût de l'engagement de
la découverte de l'autre la curiosité la
curiosité du départ et finalement qui
ont vécu une sorte de
debès un déclin sur les dix dernières
années et qui ont redémarré cette année
avec avec un nombre de départs qui
continuent à augmenter et qui a permis à
plus de 700 milles jeunes hors
mouvements scouts et bien de partir avec
une prise en charge de plus de 25000
avec l'hébergement c'est 1,7 million de
places qui sont ouvertes dans plus de
trente et une 1031 31000 accueil
collectif sans hébergement le ministère
met également en place et c'est tout
c'est toute la force de ce ministère est
uni qui s'occupe de tout le temps
du jeune de l'adolescent ou de l'enfant
avec le plan mercredi qui consiste
évidemment et c'est ce que je disais
dans mes propos liminaire à une alliance
territoriale avec les collectivités
locales pour accompagner le
développement du plan mercredi pour que
et bien les enfants les adolescents
puissent s'appuyer sur les fédérations
d'éducation populaire et finalement
apprendre tout au long de la journée
tout au long de la semaine c'est une
politique éducative que nous portons et
que nous développons en complémentarité
de l'éducation populaire constitue une
démarche qui vise évidemment assurer la
formation tout au long de la vie en
complémentarité de l'école et ses plus
de 18000 associations qui bénéficient
aujourd'hui d'un agrément éducation
populaire sur la formation des bénévoles
se posent un
un vrai sujet puisque cette crise elle a
fragilisé le monde associatif et on a vu
un certain nombre de bénévoles ne pas
revenir dans les associations alors même
si les chiffres sont pas totalement
consolidé on parle de 20 % des bénévoles
et donc se pose la question de comment
eh bien on recrute de l'envié de retour
d'abord une campagne qui a été lancée
avec le mouvement associatif et exo paix
pour rappeler mon association je l'adoré
adhère vraiment le retour mais également
le soutien aux têtes de réseaux
coordination nationale en
complémentarité des solutions sur sur le
territoire l'engagement de l'état en
faveur du monde associatif évidemment au
même niveau que l'année dernière mais
avec un renforcement de la formation des
bénévoles qui est un véritable levier de
fidélisation est également de
reconnaissance de ce qu'ils apportent à
notre un autre pays
c'est aussi le fonds de développement de
la vie associative qui évidemment
concours au financement des plans de
formation qui est doté de 8,1 millions
d'euros en 2022 et plus de 25 millions
consacrés au soutien et au
fonctionnement de l'innovation des
associations locales celle qui
finalement dessine le visage de nos
villes et de nos territoires c'est aussi
le renforcement du conte engagement
citoyen 14.4 millions d'euros qui seront
consacrés en 2022 à la couverture de ses
droits à la formation
pour les pour reconnaître encore une
fois et valoriser le l'engagement
bénévole et associatif mais ce
accompagner les associations c'est
évidemment accompagné le retour des
bénévoles leur reconnaissance le
développement d'un réel statut du
bénévole je crois que aujourd'hui plus
que jamais c'est nécessaire mais c'est
aujourd'hui c'est également faciliter la
vie la gestion d'une association on sait
à quel point la lourdeur parfois
administrative pèse sur les bénévoles et
donc nous avons des travaux stratégique
menée permettant par exemple le
développement d'outils numériques pour
que les associations n'est plus à nous
le dire qu'une fois une seule fois
déposé des documents d'identité une fois
déposé les les rapports par exemple et
donc c'est le développement de mon
contassot et de data subventions qui
sont des outils qui ont vocation à
alléger cette charge administrative et
donc c'est à l'état et de finalement
trouver l'information là où elle est
plus à l'association et en particulier
au moment des demandes de subventions je
ne serai pas beaucoup plus longue
monsieur le président je vois que le
temps file et de façon préliminaire je
souhaitais rappeler notre notre objectif
c'est l'accompagnement humain de tous
les jeunes dans leur diversité chacun
sur son territoire en transmettant des
valeurs et évidemment des repères pour
qu'ils puissent se construire et aller
vers l'autonomie que nous souhaitons
c'est un parcours de citoyenneté
totalement assuré la secrétaire d'état
va commencer par une première série de
questions en l'occurrence celle de nos
apporteurs en commençant par jacques
grosperrin rapporteur des crédits sur
l'enseignement scolaire merci monsieur
le président monsieur ministre madame la
ministre je vous remercie l'un et
l'autre ou l'une et l'autre pour
l'ensemble des éléments que vous avez
apporté j'ai noté avec intérêt vous
annonce relative à la revalorisation du
personnel de l'éducation nationale le
président en introduction allait bien
mon cri que beaucoup de travaux sont en
cours à ce jour afin de dresser un bilan
sur les mesures éducatives prises lors
de son quinquennat et les questions de
mes collègues qui permettront d'y
répondre le président en propos
liminaire à parler du record de
longévité
souvent moi je me rappelle il était
coutumier de dire pour un ministre et
d'éducation nationale - ont fait deux
choses m'ont risque d'être embêté les
exemples sont nombreux je me rappelle je
citerai pas les noms bien sûr et si
surtout pas xavier darcos que je citerai
non pas parce que laure est là mais
simplement parce que c'est aussi un
ministre et qu'il a compté moi je
voudrais simplement dire que
longévité oui mais vous avez été battus
ou second empire par victor duruy il
était ministre une inspection public de
63 69 pendant six ans il avait été même
plus tôt
et en tout cas est sollicité par
napoléon iii alors il a terminé sa
carrière pas loin de chez toi il a été
sénateur des landes a été prise en
conseil départemental et puis bon il a
fait la politique car je sais si ça se
passera ainsi pour vous dans la
continuité de ce que vous faites en tout
cas je vous le souhaite mais vous avez
battu en tout cas christian fouchet ça a
été dit fort bien dit tout à l'heure et
moi je voudrais simplement citer parce
qu'il ya des similitudes par rapport à 2
par rapport aux connards un public jeune
c'est qu'il faudrait peut-être
quelque part lui ressembler mais lorsque
de gaulle donc a choisi et fouché le
sous-ministre son premier ministre
c'était georges pompidou alors lui il
avait parlé d'un train de réformes donc
foucher c'était 83 moi même si je vois
très très forte moi je crois que chez
vous c'est un tgv de réforme et je crois
qu'on peut ne pas être d'accord sur tout
mais en tout cas on doit vous rendre
hommage par rapport au courage que vous
avez eue et au courage de madame elle a
écrit qu'il a montré à d'autres moments
à besançon sur des commentaires des
réactions aussi sur lesquels vous avez
vous avez dont je vous avais parlé on
peut pas être d'accord mais vous avez en
tout cas une vraie volonté sur réformer
l'enseignement scolaire et moi j'aurais
pété souhaité c'est pas ma première
question mais est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
pu faire un grand ministère
d'intelligence éducation nationale hors
enseignement supérieur recherche
bon je vais je vais pas me faire des
amis au niveau de madame bidane mais je
crois qu'à un moment donné ça a été
peut-être quelque chose qui aurait pu
avoir en tout cas du sens même et pour
juste pour terminer ce qu'ils s'en
fichaient aux questions fusent chez lui
il a fait un peu moins longtemps mais
ils étaient mises d'intérieur alors vous
avez bien compris ce que je veux dire
par là
militaria je pense que quelque part bon
vous avez tout compris le sens de ma
remarque donc après avoir été mise
l'éducation nationale est émise la
terreur ça aurait pu l'être bon voilà
c'est assis sa peau à l'aide peut-être
plus tard en tout cas si si les choses
ne se passent pas comme mon souhait ça
se passe nous en tout cas au niveau
présidentiel donc le tgv de réformes
elle a donc quelques remarques sur vos
propos il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
comptés dit elle président la faune l'a
bien dit au coeur c'était la
rémunération est la revalorisation qui
était très attendu et ça c'est vrai que
c'était des choses qui est important on
en avait parlé c'était le l'objet de la
problématique de mon rapport l'année
dernière cette année ce sera le sport et
c'est pour ça que je vais interroger
interpellerait par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit bien sûr ça vous permettra dé
répondre un chiffre impressionnant à
55,2 milliards c'est impressionnant cus
3% +13 % en cinq ans je ne serai pas de
ceux et vous m'avez précédé serval vous
êtes ministre
mais
lorsque certains disent oui pisa où sont
les évaluations internationales etc pisa
c'est 2018 où vous l'avez dit on avait
aussi du temps j'espère mais je suis
partie aussi de ceux qui pensent que ce
sont pas uniquement les moyens qu'il
faut comment mener né il ya des mots
résultats donc il faut que tu sais tu
qui est aussi autre chose et je crois
que le grenelle 2 de l'éducation
j'espère aura contribué à cela parce
qu'il faudrait vraiment qu'il ya un
esprit à renforcer et faire en sorte
qu'ils aient une équipe de france de
l'éducation nationale que tous les
enseignants mais depuis les ash des
enseignants les les chefs
d'établissement toute personnelle qu'on
appelle la communauté éducative qui sont
déjà concernés qui se sentent concernés
qu'ils ont montré pendant la pandémie
quoi comment donner la régularisation
c'est jose qui est important mais ils
ont besoin aussi armes aux données et
surtout les chefs d'établissement ils
ont bizarrement donné d'être assurés
parce que le train de réformes le tgv je
crois qu'il m'attend si ce taux pour
quoi bon investir par les événements
mais en tout cas il le faut parce qu'il
faut les digérer il faut les assimiler
il faut les absorber il ya comme une
théma choses qui ont été faites et je
crois beaucoup quand même à cette ppl de
directeur d'école parce que cette ppl
moment donné va changer les mentalités
dans l'assurance scolaire et surtout
dans le primaire parce qu'on sait que
les inégalités c'est notre problème nous
sur pisa ou sur d'autres sont plombées
par les élèves dont on a du mal assortis
à me donner ce qu'ils sont le plus bas
ou en difficulté
lorsqu'un élève arrive en 6e il sait ni
lire ni écrire à des difficultés il va
les garder on le sait très bien jusqu'à
la fin la troisième donc c'est quelque
chose de fondamental je veux pas être
trop long mais j'arriverai quand même à
mes questions qui seront
qui seront pas qu'ils seront qui seront
pas nombreuses parce que je veux laisser
aujourd'hui comme c'est le dernier
moment pour que chacun puisse s'exprimer
et puis vous avez compris que nous nous
avons trois minutes en tant que
rapporteur à la tribune pour s'exprimer
donc c'est seulement mort pourquoi on
peut dire les choses donc j'y serai à
mes collègues posé beaucoup de questions
qui ont trait ou en tout cas qui sont en
rapport direct avec ce que j'ai pu dire
là la première c'est celle droit de
suite par rapport à mon équipe
budgétaire donné d'air hier j'ai abordé
la question de la transmission des
valeurs de la république par l'école j
notait la nécessité de renforcer la
formation des enseignants ont valeur de
république à la fois dans la formation
commune et initial mais il ya une sous
consommation chronique des crédits en
matière de formation continue ça
s'étudie par beaucoup est ce que vous
nous indiquer les mesures prises pour
renforcer la formation des enseignants à
la laïcité c'est à dire de manière
générale quelles sont les mesures prises
pour augmenter le taux de consommation
des crédits consacrés à la formation
continue ma deuxième question ma
deuxième thématique peut vous surprendre
au premier abord mais peut-être que j'ai
des creux parce que l'année dernière
c'est à la revalorisation ça s'est bien
passé cette fois-ci là c'est le sport
c'est ça serait sera dans le cadre de
cet examen budgétaire donc c'est
l'aspect du sport à l'école il semble
que le contexte s'y prête le
rattachement des services déconcentrés
du sport la jeunesse au rectorat depuis
le 1er janvier 2021 est la perspective
des jeux olympiques et paralympiques
2024 avec la volonté de faire vivre leur
héritage donc de manière rares et sans
doute inédite une circulaire globale
relative au sport à l'école été publié
le 1er juillet 2010
je regrette néanmoins que plusieurs
acteurs la pratique sportive n'ait pas
été associé à la rédaction de ces deux
circulaires je pense essentiellement aux
collectivités locales qu on a auditionné
et aux associations de sport scolaire
pour une en ressort beaucoup de points
je vais au plus course 1 ils nous disent
qu'ils en ont respect des heures du ps
notamment à l'école primaire et deux
c'est la formation des enseignants ou un
certain nombre d'entre eux ne s'en sont
pas en position éligible pour l'enseigné
où ça et comme des anciens dans les
primaires ont du poids du mal enseigné
la musique quelle mesure mettre en place
va cesser de frein et puis enfin je
terminerai par une dernière question
très courte mais ce président est ce que
vous pouvez nous assurer que le
dispositif des 30 minutes d'activités
physiques sportives par jour et c'est de
nature à rassurer tous les incidents n'a
pas vocation à se substituer bien sûr
other dps à l'école primaire je vous
remercie excusez moi d'abord être
nathalie delattre en soi en ses devoirs
agricole
merci monsieur le président je lui ai
tout d'abord remercier monsieur le
ministre et madame à secrétaires d'état
de leurs propos liminaire messieurs
ministre dans le cadre du droit de
tirage de mon groupe rdse le sénat mis
en place une mission d'information vous
le savez sur l'enseignement agricole
plusieurs collègues de notre commission
n'en était d'ailleurs membre ayant
activement participé
malheureusement votre agenda était
incompatible avec le nôtre il nous
n'avons pas pu vous auditionné ce qui
nous a manqué c'est donc un travail
collectif fédérant tous les groupes
politiques de notre assemblée qui a
permis l'émergence de 45 propositions un
certain nombre d'entre elles concerne
ministre de l'agriculture que j'ai
d'ailleurs interpellé tout à l'heure à
l'occasion des questions au gouvernement
lui rappelons notre souhait notamment
que cet enseignement agricole reste
attaché au ministère de l'agriculture
mais plusieurs propositions concernent
l'éducation nationale et rejoignent la
problématique plus globale de
l'information et l'orientation des
élèves nous avons constaté que
l'éducation nationale avait du mal à se
séparer de ses élèves et créant parfois
même des sections concurrentes
ou bien on abandonnant simplement les
élèves en échec scolaire
nous avons auditionné plus de 80
personnes et visité
au moins
bonne vingtaine d'établissements
complément de tous ceux visités par un
par mes collègues
et les témoignages en la matière ont été
nombreux et nous avons salué d'ailleurs
les parcours de ces enfants qui d'échec
scolaire aujourd'hui ont des carrières
brillantes ou ont eu des trajectoires
que l'enseignement agricole
laura leur a offerte
donc notre mission d'information
préconise plusieurs
plusieurs axes en matière
d'orientation ou d'information
premièrement de rang forme et de
renforcer l'information tous les
enseignants sur le contenu des métiers
proposés par l'enseignement agricole
deuxièmement de prévoir de façon
obligatoire en 4e et en 3e dans le cadre
des heures annuelles d'orientation la
venue d'un proviseur de lycée agricole
et d'un directeur de maison familiale et
rurale devant les collégiens et tous les
collégiens pour permettre une
présentation de l'enseignement agricole
ou encore d'expérimenter une telle
présentation dès la cinquième dans le
cadre d'un partenariat entre un rectorat
et un draft en effet certains
établissements d'enseignement agricole
accueille des élèves dès la 4e mais pour
cela il faut une volonté forte de votre
côté monsieur le ministre est une
commande express sinon nous nous
retrouvons toujours face aux mêmes
problématiques
de fléchage d'enfants en échec scolaire
je pense que l'enseignement agricole
mérite mérite mieux je souhaitais donc
avoir votre avis monsieur ministre ces
recommandations et puis juste en clin
d'oeil pour madame la secrétaire d'état
pour sarah et lahiri dire que notre
proposition 39 indique qu'il faut
encourager les apprenants et les
établissements de l'enseignement
agricole à s'engager dans le scénic
merci
et enfin jacques bernard magner pour les
crédits jeunesse et vie associative
merci monsieur le président du nice mais
chaque oeil nous avons bien noté madame
je m'adresserai essentiellement a avoué
le ministre puisque vous nous avez
exposé les éléments du budget de la
jeunesse et de la vie associative
j'interviendrai tout à l'heure au nom du
groupe socialiste auprès du ministre ces
éléments d'éducation nationale
votre budget effectivement augment danse
pour cent c'est important mais cette
augmentation est essentiellement en
consommer par le service civique tant
mieux nous devons nous en féliciter
puisque
530 mille jeunes à ce jour qui en ont
bénéficié de 100 milles en 2022 c'est
très bien vous avez poursuivi l'effort
qui avait été engagé je veux le dire
pendant la période de crise du coc vide
on a souhaité avoir des jeunes en
service civique en ce moment où cela a
été fait c'est très bien 100 milles
supplémentaires qui sont
qui ont été répartis sur les deux années
2021-2022 très bien et puis aussi pour
le service national universel sur lequel
j'ai moins de satisfaction à voir son
développement puisque moi j'ai toujours
douté de ce dispositif
vous avez dit qu'il était là pour faire
une transmission des valeurs très bien
on peut tout utiliser votre suppléant du
cc très nécessaire mais je pensais
beaucoup
de mes collègues pensent aussi que 15 17
ans et bien âgé déjà pour pouvoir avoir
inculqué des valeurs notamment les
valeurs de la république de la
citoyenneté de vivre ensemble donc ce
pour ce qui me concerne je pense que
cette ces 100 millions 110 millions
d'euros qui sont en place et sur ses nus
pour satisfaire ce 50 mille jeunes
c'est tout à fait à mon avis c'est
irréalisable une fois de plus mais si
j'ai déjà dit ça deux fois en 2021 et en
2020 enfin pour les budgets 2021 et 2020
et à chaque fois malheureusement j'avais
raison on n'a pas pu mais il y avait un
contexte sanitaire qui pouvait
éventuellement être invoqué d'athus de
cette question là c'était vraiment de
votre faute mais continuer là-dessus en
voulant doubler l'effectif avec un
doublement parce que du budget et cette
année vous allez nous le dira toute
heure combien ont été consommés combien
pour combien de jeunes puisqu'il était
prévu 25000 jeunes je ne pense pas qu'on
y soit arrivé et je même cru entendre
que ce rappel
la candidature à volontaires une
trentaine un peu plus d'une trentaine de
milles candidature avait été faite quand
vous allez proposer 50 me pose comment
allez vous faire pour en avoir 50 mille
parce que j'imagine que ceux qui étaient
volontaires se sont déjà manifestés et
je crains que cet appel au volontariat
qui devrait se déboucher sur une
obligation puisque ces choses qui sera
universel et donc pour tous les jeunes
avec une obligation tout cela nous nous
interpelle un peu et nous inquiète je
voudrais en parallèle à partir de ces
sommes importantes qui sont mobilisés
sur l'essai nu dire qu'il faudrait
prévoir par contre de mobiliser des
sommes importantes sur les colonisations
ces séjours collectifs de mineurs
aujourd'hui et vous le savez sont en
diminution d'effectifs depuis une
dizaine d'années alors est-ce que c'est
l'époque qui le veut la période que nous
vivons il n'y est pas pour rien non plus
mais on a en gros 160 mille enfants par
an en moins depuis une dizaine d'années
et aujourd'hui on craint que petit à
petit si on n'y prend garde ses séjours
pour jeunes pour enfants pour les
mineurs en particulier collectifs vont
petit à petit non pas disparaître
peut-être mais être réservé une toute
petite catégorie dos de nos enfants
alors que les les faits de lait français
au pour les trois quarts d'entre eux
approuvent sont d'accord pour les
colonies de vacances alors est-ce qu'ils
essaient pour certains un problème de
l'adhésion à ce qu'est le séjour de
collectifs de mineurs ou ce que ce sont
des problèmes financiers
j'imagine que vous avez des solutions à
vous de les dire et pour essayer de
convaincre
les parents de ces enfants du bien fondé
allez encore une vacance pour leurs
enfants et par contre je pense que nous
pourrions peut-être star de ce qui a été
fait pour domaine culturel domaine
sportif et créer peut-être ce que l'on
pourrait appeler alors j'ai pas inventé
donnons le pascolo qui permettrait
d'aider financièrement alors pas
spécifiquement justement tous ceux qui
déjà sont aidés par la caf parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup dès 15h que j'avais mais
elle apporte déjà beaucoup de solutions
beaucoup d' aide à ces séjours mais
aussi pour ses classes moyennes qui
aujourd'hui font des choix différents
que ceux d'envoyer leurs enfants en
colonie parce que bien ils sont à la
limite des aides et ne les ont pas aussi
facilement qu'il faudrait donc peut-être
qu'on pourrait fléchir alors là aussi je
vous laisse l'initiative puisque j'ai
des propositions vous faire je les ferai
lors de la séance avec un amendement
mais j'imagine que vous avez réfléchi
puisque vous l'avez dit vous allez
pouvoir nous faire des propositions dans
ce domaine pour essayer d'apporter un
dispositif nouveau pour inciter les
enfants à aller en colonie de vacances
parce que à mon avis quand ils en 9 ans
10 ans 11 ans et plus favorable pour
commencer à leur inculquer les valeurs
de la citoyenneté de la république j'en
ai aussi vous laisser répondre à cette
première série de questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
alors je vais savoir répondre à ses
auteurs d'un gros pépin je le remercie
pour son port son propos initial
d'avoir mis la concurrence avec le
second empire désormais mais bon là pour
l'instant gens comme vous le savez je me
situe dans la république
et mais en tout cas je pense que cet
enjeu premièrement de longévité
deuxièmement de de spectre large sur les
enjeux éducatifs ce double enjeu me
paraît en effet devoir aller au delà du
quinquennat et je l'espère inspiré les
temps futurs
ensuite sur vos questions spécifiques
d'abord même merci aussi de ce que vous
avez dit sur la proposition de loi sur
les directeurs d'école je pense que
c'est en effet un pas important et pour
lequel le sénat a beaucoup contribué
aussi d'ailleurs et donc on arrive
justement à me semble-t-il à ce type de
consensus
ou de quasi consensus que l'on peut
rechercher
dans l'intérêt général
ensuite donc s'agissant de consommation
vous avez qualifié de chronique des
crédits de la formation continue
vous m'avez interrogé sur finalement une
manière de mieux les dépenser dans les
temps à venir alors plusieurs remarques
vous avez pointé le sujet de la laïcité
et des formations sur la laïcité
je vous répondrai par trois 3 éléments
d'abord
nous avons
souhaité moderniser la formation
continue des professeurs non seulement
en y consacrant plus de crédits et en
consommant en 2022 je le pense la
totalité des crédits d'une part par le
fait de créer des écoles académiques de
formation continue et donc d'avoir dans
chaque rectorat
une manière renouvelée de concevoir la
formation continue notamment en étant
plus attentifs aux besoins du terrain
deuxièmement un développement de la
formation continue à distance la crise
sanitaire a été l'occasion d'un
changement assez radical en la matière
notamment par le recentrage de
l'institution canopée sur cet enjeu de
la formation continue à distance et ce
sont des dizaines de milliers de
professeurs qui ont été concernés par
cette formation continue à distance
c'est ces derniers mois
en
en troisième lieu nous avons un
des
programmes de formation pour le premier
degré volontariste un peu consommateur
de budget aussi c'est le plan français
le plan mathématique qui sont organisées
dans ce que nous avons des
constellations c'est à dire des systèmes
assez horizontaux permettant à des
groupes de professeurs d'être formés
ensemble à partir de besoins identifiés
par eux mêmes ce plan français ce plan
mathématique ont commencé depuis un an
et demi maintenant le plan mathématique
inspiré par le rapport villani torossian
et c'est une formation continue d'après
les premières enquêtes que nous menons
qui semble donner satisfaction elle est
faite pour que tous professeurs des
écoles puissent en bénéficier
sur une durée de cinq ans et donc ça
fait partie d'une stratégie générale de
réhaussement de notre niveau du niveau
des enfants des élèves de france en
français et en mathématiques enfin et
puisque vous avez directement fait
référence est en effet un nouveau
volontariste sur la formation aux
valeurs de la république et laïcité et
c'est ainsi que nous avons lancé un
nouveau cycle dans la dans la suite du
rapport aux mains pour former en
formation continue tous les professeurs
de france dont près de 1 million de
personnes tous cas 850000 mais ça fait 1
million quand on compte aussi les
personnels non enseignants qui vont être
formés et cette formation donc se fait
grâce à des formateurs de formateurs
auxquels je me suis adressé il ya
maintenant trois semaines qui sont au
nombre de 1000 un peu plus même nous
appelons les mines mais ils sont mille
cent et 7 cette formation va être aussi
au coeur des enjeux de formation
continue de l'année 2022 et des crédits
budgétaires qui sont qui sont consacrés
sur le sport à l'école
merci là aussi de ce que vous avez dit
et je sais le l'importance que vous
attachez à juste titre à cette question
en effet la circulaire du 1er juillet
est est importante et en effet il ya
plusieurs questions qui doivent être
regardées en face notamment le non
respect du temps de paix s à l'école
primaire donc non nous donnant des
consignes claires sur le fait que cela
doit l'être mais nous développons aussi
puisque nous sommes désormais ministère
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports des collabos des
collaborations beaucoup plus forte avec
le monde du sport oui comme vous le
savez fort bien le le sujet se pose en
des termes différents dans le premier
degré dans le second degré puisqu'il
n'ya pas de professeurs de ps dans le
premier degré d'où l'opération un club
une école que j'ai lancée avec roxana
maracineanu à la rentrée qui est fait
pour qu'il y ait un appareillage
jumelage automatise systématique d'un
club avec une école primaire en france
et nous faisons avec beaucoup plus de
force en étant aussi le ministère des
sports en même temps que ministère de
l'éducation nationale et concrètement ça
veut dire des conventions avec les
fédérations où nous visons aussi le
sujet des 30 minutes d'activité physique
par jour que vous avez évoqué et qui en
effet ont vocation à se généraliser en
france nous nous sommes très ambitieux
dès l'année 2000 21 22 après les
premières environ 3000 écoles qui sont
entrées dans le dispositif en 2020 2021
et j'aimerais réussir à ce qui est la
moitié des écoles au moins en 21 22 qui
rentre dans le dispositif il ne se
substituera pas au temps de ps c'est
vraiment en plus mais ça doit garantir
le fait que tous nos élèves puissent 30
minutes par jour avoir une activité
physique et vous savez il ya un enjeu de
santé publique considérable en plus
d'autres enjeux liés au score
s'agissant des questions posées par
madame la sénatrice nathalie delattre au
titre de l'enseignement agricole je
voudrais d'abord vous dire que votre
votre rapport a retenu toute mon
attention toute notre attention et je
suis assez en phase je suis complètement
en phase avec l'esprit est plutôt en
phase avec la plupart des propositions
donc très ouvert à promouvoir une bonne
partie des idées que vous poussez
certaines sont déjà d'ailleurs un peu en
entamer enfin amorcé avec
en tout cas un état d'esprit qui est
conforme à ce que vous souhaitez quand
vous dites l'éducation du national a du
mal à se séparer de ses élèves
je vous aime c'est absolument pas la
consigne générale données dans le
système
j'ai signé avec le ministre de
l'agriculture précédent dit guillaume
est évidemment poursuivi par julie en
normandie une convention très clair pour
faire la promotion d'enseignement
agricole à l'éducation nationale et
notamment l'âge du collège c'est
évidemment très important que j'ai
toujours eu beaucoup de référence pour
l'enseignement agricole qui apporte
beaucoup et qui est très complémentaire
donc je considère pas du tout cas une
quelconque compétition j'observe
d'ailleurs que le ministère de
l'agriculture a aussi été très articulé
à nous mêmes dans différents moments
notamment la réforme du lycée pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir se moderniser
notez aussi que le
l'enseignement que nous avons retenu
dans la réforme du lycée un enseignement
spécialité qui était typique de
l'enseignement agricole et notre
politique n'est absolument pas de créer
de la compétition localement c'est
pourquoi lorsque quelque chose de cette
nature est observé il faut le signaler
pour analyser voir ce qu'il en est en
tout cas y'a rien de volontaire à
l'échelle nationale je suis même passion
qui est que ce soit volontaire à
l'échelle locale en tout état de cause
il faut regarder de quoi on parle mais
le but n'est pas celui-là est au
contraire le but est vraiment une vraie
complémentarité
les données de rentrée nous permettent
de voir sauf erreur de ma part que la
l'hémorragie a stoppé autrement dit nous
avons réussi justement à ce que la
baisse continue observée tout au long
des dernières années de nombreuses
dernières années n'est plus et que nous
avons un petit rebond que je crois liés
à cette convention signée avec le
ministère de l'agriculture et avec la
politique qui va avec c'est notamment
une petit dorian d'information et
d'orientation dès la classe de 4e pour
faire la promotion des opportunités
offertes par l'enseignement agricole
donc la volonté est là le la convergence
avec ce que vous souhaitez elle est là
aussi et c'est vrai que le sujet de
l'information et l'orientation est
particulièrement important dans ce
contexte ainsi que celui la carte des
formations dans les deux cas
on
va vraiment je crois dans la botte dans
la direction que vous souhaitez et on
peut peut-être aller plus loin à la
lumière des recommandations vous faites
en tout cas je vous affiche non une
totale ouverture sur ces questions et
nous sommes évidemment en phase avec
julien de normandie nous serons
d'ailleurs tous les deux dans
l'hémicycle au moment de la discussion
parlementaire on pourra donc poursuivre
d'une manière dont vous verrez
l'harmonie les réponses à vos questions
voilà donc pour cette audition de jean
michel blanquer air devant la